emmanuel mac ont donné une interview au
jt de tf1 et france 2 une prise de
parole très attendu plus de vern 2 5
millions de téléspectateurs hier et tmp
frais 1 million quand même merci merci à
vous cet après midi lors d'une
conférence de presse le premier ministre
et plusieurs ministres ont détaillé les
mesures de ce couvre-feu alors sakho
c'est le couvre-feu pour les nuls
alors ça que la première question c'est
ça commence quand ce coup voient oui bah
alors c'est donc c'est de 21h à 6h tous
les jouets s'attendre d'ici ça et ça
commence vendredi à zéro heure voilà ce
que moi j'avais compris samedi vendredi
à zéro heure
ça veut dire qu à zéro heure une dans le
vendredi dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi
tu dois être chez toi sinon tu prends
135 voilà donc on est à la maison vous
avez bien compris parce qu'en fait c'est
samedi à zéro heure exactement vrai dire
que ces nombreux d'hiver si ma chérie ça
va durer pendant au moins quatre
semaines
ça pourrait continuer deux semaines de
plus soit jusqu'au 1er décembre
on admire si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas qu'est ce que je risque si
je sors dans la rue après 21h voulait
lui une amende de 135 euros en cas de
récidive dans les quinze jours la
demande s'élèvera à 1500 euros et s
pression basse si on se fait prendre
trop emphatique la troisième fois c'est
c'est 3750 euros d'amendé
je suis moi dont 15 en prison et 15000
zone 15 ans de placard pour kia selon un
sondage harris 6% des français assurent
qu'ils ne respecteront pas le couvre-feu
qu'est ce qui se passe rien elle c'est
n'importe quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe
troisième fois combien premier 200 m
trop fort 1750 euros d'en faire un
possible buybuy vous faut pas le faire
oui mais j'ai dit allez les bouchons non
mais non aux bouchons et maintenant mes
meilleurs souvenirs parfois dans les
mots espoir et trois fois dans la
mauvaise foi savent alors qui pourra
sortir entre 21h et 6h du matin une
attestation sera obligatoire au jeu s'y
fait tous vos déplacements entre haute
et dockers et d'horaires et ceux qui
sont en tan et d'imprimantes
elle sera dispo sur les téléphones ne
vous inquiétez pas les sorties
autorisées raisons professionnelles ou
de santé pour aider un proche en
situation de dépendance pour des raisons
de transport et pour sortir votre animal
de compagnie à la moi j'ai envie que
j'ai d'église la faute à mourir de nival
pour ce faire on a tous des copains de
monter ce qu'ils ont déjà appelé exemple
vous avez un chien ce qu'on pourra le ce
mois là bas bien sûr alors mais je vous
dis oui mais en même temps on peut
sortir une heure aux chiens une heure
maximum une heure une heure maxi à côté
de soi à côté de chez soi à le connaître
ce soir voilà dans les environs on va
pas sortir le chien tu partirais sinon
il vous faut plusieurs chiens quoi dans
plusieurs films voilà est en fait voilà
c'est ça oui ah bon moi j'ai un copain
kalou et son chien effectivement des
gens louis et il a juste oublié c'est
que quand ils passaient devant un
commissariat le chien il a fini par
reconnaître les gens du commissariat
qu'il allait vers eux en frétillant
temps qu'il tombe bien vu que le chien
était toujours le même mais que les gens
changeaient d'aller chez look un toutou
plus là si tel venir chez moi pourquoi
cij organise une soirée le ministre de
l'intérieur annoncé que douze mille
policiers et gendarmes seront mobilisés
pour faire respecter le cours eux dit
non si j'ai entendu que c'était la fête
là c'est moi je suis tout seul je
m'éclate ça se passait comme ça voilà
ils vont pas venir chez moi s'ils
organisent une soirée raclette merguez
peux vous dire c'est terminé il confie
ce que tout la merguez des raclettes et
terminer oui parce qu'elle a déjà plein
de gens notamment des jeunes qui ont dit
bah on va louer un appartement pour
savez grande soirée
du coup le ministre de l'intérieur à
dire attention on passera on circulera
sinon ça va recommencer une et pyjama
party exactement est ce que je pourrais
aller au resto au cinéma au théâtre voir
ahmad le football reste au site envie de
te faire un petit dîner avec ta meuf ou
ton pote c'est bon tu peux chaud que tu
dois finir pour un dessert avant 20h30
avec des yeux le vin en gros le but
c'est bien être à la maison avant 21h
heure du début du couvre-feu par contre
si tu as faim après 21h t'as rien dans
ton frigo
tu pourras quand même te faire livrer
voyons ça sert pas heureusement s'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont dit ouais ce
qu'on pourra se faire livrer tout ça
cinéma pour aller au cinéma mais pas
après 21h il en est de même pour les
théâtres les pièces ne pourront pas
jouer après 21h c'est d'aller le sport
c'est plus compliqué pour le sport si
les rencontres auront bien lieu aux
horaires prévus normalement les matches
qui se joueront dans les neuf métropoles
affecté devront se dérouler à huis clos
et non plus devant mille spectateurs la
terminer il y aura voilà et si tu es un
grand sportif comme benjamin castaldi
allure pourra pas s'entraîner après 21h
et ouais et donc c'est dommage pour
développer les nourrices entre ouvre
alors lessard et uri salle rios et ce à
partir de 9h on peut plus être dans la
rue mais si on va au resto et qu'on
reste dans le resto jusqu'à 6 heures du
matin fermé et impartiaux voulait faire
la plonge dans le resto c'est votre
problème